foreign
welcome to how the light gets in thank
you hello nice to speak to you
so what is happiness is it a feeling
like Pleasure and Pain or is it
something different
that's a good place to start well so
about two and a half thousand years of
ethical discourse about it so we're
probably not going to get an answer in
the next two and a half minutes but
having said that I think it's located in
our experiences
in what we do and how we feel based on
what we do and who we're with and what
we think about
and it comes in Twin set of experiences
I think on the one hand pleasure
Joy contentment all the adjectives that
we use for the positive emotions
and then the negative emotions that are
also the obverse of the pleasure so
there will be pain and anger and worry
and stress it's interesting that we have
many more negative additives that we do
have positive ones so that's the first
set of experiences pleasure as I call it
the other is purpose
still located in our experiences that in
what we do who we're with and what we
think about but things that feel like
they're worthwhile meaningful fulfilling
they have a point to them and the
opposite of those would be futility and
pointlessness and things that feel like
they're a waste of time
um and I argue that
for all of us
we're trying to find a balance between
pleasure and purpose it's not to say
that it's the same for everybody you
might be driven more by one I might be
more by the other but each of us is
trying to work out that balance between
things that we find pleasurable on the
one hand and things that we find
purposeful on the other
so take your point uh there's no one
formula that's going to fit everyone
but is there a question of whether we're
very good at identifying the things that
make us happy so are people good at
knowing what is it that makes them happy
are we quite bad at it yeah pursue
things that we think are going to make
us happy but don't actually make us
happy it's a really good question I
spend I spend so much of my life saying
people are different we're heterogeneous
there's no one-size-fits-all approach
and then I go into one size fits-all
approaches
um
the the thing that we're that we that we
do all share to some large degree is
that we're not particularly good
futurians we're not particularly good at
being able to predict
which things will impact Us in which
ways and for how long that's the key
thing because everything around
happiness everything around what we do
and how we feel is driven by attention
what we pay attention to and what we're
not very good at being able to predict
is how much attention something will
draw to itself into the longer term
right so for example I might imagine a
pay rise
um it is true that the pay rise will
make me feel good when I first get it
because I'm paying attention to it but
what I'm not particularly good at being
able to forecast is how I will withdraw
attention very quickly from it and some
things continue to draw attention to
themselves
um anxiety depression mental health
problems do but most things in life we
withdraw attention relatively quickly
and we're not particularly good at
predicting that
what do you think is the source of kind
of distorted views about uh happiness we
have narratives about what makes people
happy we find them in films we find them
in advertising in popular culture in
general what what's the source of kind
of a misconception of happiness
yeah it's a good question I mean there's
lots of stories around what should make
us happy
um I've been very interested in those
narratives and we're not the etiology of
them not where they come from but the
consequences that they have and they do
prescribe a one-size-fits-all approach
you know it's like be rich be successful
be smart get married have kids
all of which for
well actually let's say two things first
of all the success status income
education
are good to a point right I mean it is
true and we shouldn't skate over this
that poverty lack of social standing
lack of Education makes people miserable
so it's right that The Human Condition
will be motivated for more of those
things when we're miserable
but we quickly reached a point where the
constant accumulation of them is like an
addiction that we have this kind of more
please irrespective of how much we have
when very rarely will we say just enough
that we reach a point where we have
enough of those things that we can stop
or slow down or pay attention to other
things that will make us happy in the
case of marriage and kids well
um there are no good rcts randomized
controlled trials where we allocate
children to some people and not to
others that would be a beauty response I
[ __ ] love to do that but I wouldn't
get ethics approval um so we've got lots
of correlational associations right we
can't really know what the counter
Factor would have been
um but the data around most of these
things shows huge variation
and we'll all know people whose kids are
a blessing to them and many people
probably many more people actually whose
kids are a real pain
um and so knowing those these things is
is really hard but we have these stories
that prescribe that a grown-up is
somebody who gets married and has kids
and you're not really you know a fully
fledged adult particularly if you're
female that's that's really the story
you meet a single woman who hasn't had
children at 40 and you know people will
say up less you know right she's
actually doing fine
without a husband or without kids but
the story is so powerful that that's
something that often she you know
sometimes he you know ought to be
motivated for so these narratives could
be good for us they can provide
coherence they can provide structure and
order to an otherwise chaotic world but
at the same time they can get in the way
of people leading lives that are
authentic and true to themselves
so happiness is in one sense it's kind
of very personal very private thing and
in some other cases it's quite a public
thing and a concern of public policy and
for many years we've been using a
measure to to sort of claim how well a
country is doing and how how happy the
people in it are and that's GDP right
how much money the country as a whole is
making basically
but you've been arguing that that's not
a very good measure of of how well
people are doing actually in society and
that we should replace it with something
else what should we replace it with yeah
it's interesting that the economic
activity measures were
intended to measure activity and not
measures of welfare they weren't
intended to be translated into measures
of success but they've almost been sort
of converted into that over time and we
do you're right we see economic growth
as being something that is good for us
again irrespective of what level we're
at and how much we have and the
sacrifices that we might be making to
pursue it that's really quite
significant
um and and of course those measures
don't account for the non-market
transactions that you know take place
the time that we spend having a laugh
with one another doesn't generate
economic output so it's not measured so
the time that we spent having to laugh
with one another all to feature
somewhere in our metrics that we use to
guide policy decisions
um and I think sometimes I think for
policy I'd rather use the term misery
and suffering reduction
than happiness promotion it's almost
like you can sort of take the piss a
little bit out of happiness you know as
a sort of soft woolly polity goal but
you'd have to be pretty sadistic as a
policy maker not to want to reduce
misery and suffering so I think
sometimes the language matters
um and I think it's incumbent on public
policy makers to reduce real experience
suffering by as much as they can what
about measuring well-being like how does
a policy maker go about
sort of evaluating how much well-being
there is in a society yeah again I mean
I've said for a while I'd love to find
out how happy you are without asking you
right and maybe with modern Technologies
and observational data there's ways in
which I can infer that still the best
and simplest ways just to ask you how
you feel right so if you go to the
doctors and you've got a pain in your
knee
he or she will ask you how much it hurts
right they haven't got access to how it
feels and it's that subjective
experience sometimes people will say oh
happiness is all subjective I'm like
well that's the point our experiences of
Life are entirely subjective
um I've got tattoos and people ask me do
they hurt I said well I can say how much
they hurt me I have no idea anyone who
goes to a tattoo it will say you know
some people are screaming in pain for
exactly the same you know the for
exactly the same tattoo in the same
place as someone else is sitting there
not in pain it's that experience that
really matters and that's what we should
be measuring more directly
so one question I guess is like even if
we said okay there are ways of measuring
people's well-being and maybe there are
issues with subjectivity maybe there's a
way of resolving those but say we find a
way of evaluating well-being is that
necessarily going to be a good guide to
public policy
and I'm thinking here of like some
counter examples for example during the
pandemic right there were lockdowns and
we now know that lockdowns were pretty
terrible for people's well-being right
they uh increase mental health problems
and especially with children in school
and so on
so if a policy maker was to kind of
evaluate that policy in the on the basis
of well-being would they have made the
right choice or would they have been
misguided
yeah it's a super question I mean it's a
the whole of kobit opens up a whole raft
of questions and issues coming back to
narratives there was a really powerful
narrative
in the policy responses to preserve life
at all costs
um and it was literally focusing only
therefore on preventing deaths from
covid as the policy response if it was
like the morally
Superior approach to policy because the
counter narratives like what are the
Alternatives well let people die clearly
not that
um proportionately balanced costs and
benefits that's actually the most
powerful cancer but it's much weaker as
a story so when you're selling a story
to the public much harder to say balance
costs and benefits but that's what we
should have been doing and I do think
that had we been doing that more more
even at all
um taking account of life expectancy
differences not just lives but life
experiences as well how people are
living and how well they're going to
live then we would have had a different
set of policy responses that would have
allowed people to engage in more social
contact than we did and actually even if
you don't care about happiness we know
that loneliness is a massive causal
Factor on how soon people die so even if
we only cared about life life expectancy
we would have cared much more about
social isolation than we did
so if we if we put aside these kind of
extreme cases of you know lockdowns and
social isolation and so on you mentioned
loneliness that's quite a sort of
personal
uh kind of situation someone finds
themselves in can the state really
intervene in things that affect our kind
of day-to-day sort of personal life in
any way what kind of policies are we
thinking here that would be would it be
able to affect that it's a really good
question about the role of the state
because I say it is because from a
personal perspective
my view towards the state has changed
significantly over the two years of the
policy responses to the pandemic I've
become much less trusting of State
intervention than I was before I mean
that's really I don't know yeah I think
there has been a shift in me I feel more
libertarian instincts now than maybe I
did before because I saw the power of
the state and felt very uncomfortable
with it
um and so it does remind us irrespective
of whether our personal views have
changed on this the a lot of these
interventions particularly around social
isolation around individual isolation
around Social Capital will be done
through non-state means through
Community interventions through people
coming together away from
statist interventions
um but it will still require a little
bit of a nudge and a shove here and
there
um from the state in order to
address some of the challenges that we
face
around loneliness around you know the
amount of time that we spend the little
amount of time that we spend genuinely
enjoying ourselves
we talked earlier about how each of us
has a sort of kind of personal measure
of you know what's the right balance
between pleasure and purpose and all the
rest of it
what about happiness across different
cultures does that kind of change and if
so how does that affect how you know
Multicultural societies like say you
know the one in the UK
um is to be treated differently than a
kind of more monocultural Society yeah
it's a good question about cultures I
one of the things I realized that lots
of us all of us do actually it's
probably not just academics as we start
a sentence or a stream of Consciousness
with really good evidence-based stuff
and then we start Meandering into stuff
that's less clear than making [ __ ] up at
the end and I don't want to start making
stuff up I actually have to say that my
my knowledge and understanding of
cultural variations is relatively weak
and so I would be giving you not much
more than a lay person's interpretation
of that evidence I'd want to stick to
stuff when I when I tell you something I
want you to know that I'm saying it
because I know the answer and not
because I'm making it up and I do and
I'm and I'm not I I you know it kind of
makes me feel quite ignorant in a way
that I'm very most of most of what I
think I know about happiness comes from
English-speaking countries comes from
English-speaking populations
um comes from UK and U.S data largely
and so I'm kind of speaking a bit
outside of my comfort zone to say
anything when it comes to to the US and
the UK are you finding any significant
differences or are you at a a Long View
do they look quite similar in terms of
that yeah so much is it expected turns
on what we ask people and the way that
we define happiness we we have a very
widely used question which is asking
people how satisfied they are with their
lives overall that's a very commonly
used question wording varies but it's
basically a sort of reflective question
um and I have been quite critical of
that question because it doesn't tap
into the experiential self quite so much
right so you know when I reflect upon my
life how well is it going well I don't
reflect upon it very often actually I
live it most of the time so
um we get different answers when we look
more directly at people's experiences
and I think that when we when we do that
like for example in the Life
satisfaction data the most robust
finding is the u-shaping age right it's
uh it's across pretty much every country
in the world that people in their
midlife
are the least happy compared to the
younger and the older people as someone
who's coming just through the bottom of
the curve I look at young people in
pity rather than Envy because I'm going
up the curve now as I get older they're
falling down the bottom
um but when we look at feelings and
emotions it's much less clear
um there's some suggestion that young
people experience less purpose than
people like young like people in their
early 20s experience less purpose than
people that are older and the and the
pleasure graph is a little bit more
complicated but
um the most robust finding on age comes
from the life satisfaction data you
mentioned earlier Parenthood and how it
can be quite a challenging experience
for some people yes and so if you ask
parents you know what was the best
moment in your day they almost never you
know say oh when I was with my child but
it's usually the opposite of like when
they finally had some time on their own
and yet on the other hand there's this
kind of issue of like purpose that if
you know that somehow they feel more
overly satisfied so are these things
clashing so is life satisfaction can it
be at odds with how happy you feel day
to day in your experiences yeah I think
it 10. I I there's a couple of reasons
why I started thinking about purposes
and experience
and one of those was my decision to to
have kids where all the happiness data
would have suggested that I shouldn't
have bothered
or at least at best neutral I was
thinking well maybe there's something in
the experiences of time I spent with my
children that feels purposeful and and I
think that's been true
um but I could just be [ __ ] deluding
myself it could be cognitive dissonance
writ large but actually now I've got
them I've got to find some way in which
they're going to make me happy to stop
me killing them um but it but but it's
um it's quite interesting looking at uh
what I wrote about children in the two
books that I wrote the ages that they
were when I wrote the books so when I
wrote Happiness by Design the kids were
young like three three four years old
horrible I mean I don't know anybody I
had a friend who said to me I was like I
think they were turning in five and I'm
like when am I going to enjoy this and
he said listen if you enjoy the
conversation with a five-year-old you're
not fit to be a parent I took that as
quite comforting
um but then when I wrote Happy Ever
After
um they were like 10 9 10 11 so much
nicer so much more fun to be round like
proper little people now they're
teenagers I think I might I think my
views might change and so it's really
important actually that point about
things changing over the life course not
just of your children but your own life
and this idea that you sort of take a
snapshot at One Moment In Time and can
say this is what should make you happy
well it's obviously going to change
you mentioned to me earlier you don't
like being asked whether you're happy or
not but do you think that we all to some
extent feel this pressure of being happy
and is that pressure somehow an obstacle
to actually kind of living our life and
enjoying it rather than constantly
worrying about are we happy enough what
can we do to get become more happy yeah
like like I said before you know poverty
makes people miserable but you don't
want to be accumulating too much
you want to be thinking about what makes
you happy and getting some sort of audit
and some feedback but you don't want to
be thinking about it too hard all of the
time because then it becomes
all-consuming and you're going to be
miserable thinking about how happy you
are so I think it's what I what I'd like
to think is that we can sort of do these
little audits do these light touch
assessments of the things that make us
feel good and things that don't and then
design our environments in ways that
let's get on with doing the things that
make us feel better and not doing the
things that make us feel worse without
having to think too hard about it
afterwards where's your work on
happiness taking you next
good question I've moved I've moved into
an interest in polarization and
taking sides
um that's the working title for my next
book
um I did a dark rabbit podcast at the
lse last year you know that that rabbit
illusion it's a nice metaphor for how we
become polarized you start seeing the
image one way
you see it's a dark everyone and you
surround yourself with people who say it
similarly until in the end how could it
possibly be a rabbit and I'm very
interested in our reluctance to
genuinely listen to people that disagree
with us
um everyone will say I like people
disagree actually we don't right we just
want people to nod their head in
agreement rather than shake it in
disapproval so I'm really interested in
thinking about how we can design
environments in ways that make it easier
for us to listen to people that
we don't agree with and I think that's
been really interesting for me during
the covid you know times is that I have
found friends
that I would wouldn't have otherwise
known as being friends because we've
agreed on particular responses or the
responses that we should have had but
didn't but disagree on so many other
issues
um
and also you can just have friends that
disagree with you about everything
but but rarely we do
um so I'm really kind of interested in
that I don't know it's interesting from
a happiness lens I've kind of approached
that not not necessarily through a
happiness lens but through a more of a
kind of I don't know tolerance
understanding social progress lens yeah
I know whether you know it's probably a
lot of the time that that tolerance will
make us miserable so I'm kind of that's
that's a really interesting thing to
pick apart as someone who's who thinks
it's all about happiness well kind of
will I be challenged a bit more on that
when I get more into the polarization
issues Paul Dolan thank you very much
thank you so much foreign
talks and interviews subscribe today to
The Institute of Art and ideas for IAI
TV